.
Bonsoir.
On a reçu des centaines de
questions Gédéon Jean jeudi
défend va trouver dans prend
beaucoup pour acquis des choses.
J'ai cette question pour vous.
Serait-il possible que la
lenteur et les difficultés de
l'avancée des troupes russes ne
soit qu'une ruse pour mieux
attaquait éventuellement?
- Je crois qu'elle stratégie
plutôt claire. La lenteur et du
à la résistance des ukrainien.
Sûrement qu'on a q q q q q q q a
prendra le temps.
- Qui va pouououour la
reconstruction? La Russie?
- Oui Patrice c'est une question
s s s se poser plus tard. Donc
je vais y réponse plus tard.- -.
- Moi je dirais que ça dépend de
l'Ukraine au terme de la guerre.
l'origine. Un des points
d'origine du conflit. À que
demande d'adhésion à l'OTAN?
Quels sont les critères po
accepter cette demande? Sur
quels critères y a dé
opposent.
- C'est au l l l l l l l l l l e
au plan d'adhésion. Donc une
éventuelle promesse d'adhésion.
Qui n'était rien de promis parce
qu'i
eft.t.t.t.t.t. Démocratie
respect des minorités. Ne pas
avoir de conflit sur sonoioioioe
les conflits. Ça fonctionne
aussi par consensus. La France
et l'Allemagne s'opposait à ce
que l'Ukraine par crainte que la
- Française Allemagne savait
provocation s'il disait oui.
j'ajouterai c'est que le
gouvernement amérinénénénénénéné
à l'époque par le
cet effet avertir: ne faites
pas ça n'allait pas dans cette
perc r r r r r r r r r r r r r à
Moscou. Prise en américain n'a
pa'é'é'é'é'é'é'é'époque.
que vous devenez de dire, ça ne
veut pas dire que c'est une
- Absolument pas.
réactions historiques. Qu'est-ce
que Vladimir Poutine gagnera à
millions de personnes ont fui et
dont beaucoup d'institutions et
d'immeubles seront des tripes?
- C'est vraiment de sens à
comprendre de notre point de
vue. C'est cette idée de
redonner la grandeur la Ru
de créer sa sphère
Pour plusieurs Russes qui
voyaient comme l'Ukraine comme
une source de menace
se passe st t t t t t t t t t dt
que c'est là l'Ukraine qui
menace la Russie. Difficile pour
nous p'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'a
qui a été véhiculé dans les
médiasemememememememememement de
Monsieur Poutine. Lui se voit un
peu comme celui qui pourraita ël
Jacob à cette grande nationésése
faire.
- Redonner la force la Russie et
empêcher l'Ukraine de tomber
dans le giron occidental. Le m
conquête, tel qu'il est utilisé
s'applique seulement si vous
voyez Vladimir Poutine comme
l'empire soviétique. Si vous le
regardez de façon plus i
si l'objectif fondamental c'est
d'empêcher l'Ukraine de devenir
une démocratie fonctio
un membre de l'union européenne,
on apprenait son
conquérir. On a seulement
besoin, je
rappelle on a peut-être
simpererererererererererererme
besoin de le détruire ce pays-
là. Il y a ça garder en tête.
usususususususususususustin. Que
font les partis d'opposition au
des parties prorusse. Quels sont
se sont ralliés au président
ukrainien? Où ils sont prorusset
qu'il voulait que la Russiequitn
qui voulait un cessez-le-feu.
Ils veulent redonner
a vraiment eu un changement. Ce
sera définitif la guerre à
rallier les ukrainien au désir
d'indépendance. C'est contre-
productif du côté russe.
- Poutine a galvanisé tout
ukrainien mêmes ceux qui étaient
prorusse d'une certaine
question quels sont les
relations des pays d
l'Amérique du Sud et de
l'Afrique avec l
- Et vous voulez évidemment une
répo
pay y y y y y y y y y y y y y a
plusieurs pays en Amériqueououos
créés égaux en termes
PaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaParààs
quatre fois le PIB du pays
l'Argentine. Très peu de gens
parlent de l'exemple du Brésil.
La relation entre Bolsonaro etle
le quartier comme étant trop
proche. Depuis l'arrivée de Jo
contraire, le Brésil s'est
abstenu de condamner l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine. Ça
revient pas dire que c'est un le
bien-être de la Russie, servi à
dire que c'est extr
- Sans parler de la Chine.
- Absolument,
incontournable. C'est celui qui
peut permettre la Russie de
co
voit le que la Chine tempère les
ardeurs parce qu'elle expose ses
ninininininininininininininininn
européenne les États-Unis.ununue
de neutralité prorusse c'est-à-
dire très ambigu sur ce qu'ellee
et le Shin a dit qu'elle
explorait l'idée. Elle condamnee
jouer sur la clôture cas
présent.nvnvnvnvnvnvnvnvnvnvnvns
humanitaires pour les réfugiéste
les faire voyager encore plus
loin car d'autres pays d'Europee
excellente question parce quenaa
place au Beyoncé Killian
communauté crie nous nous paon t
aille plus loin. Qu'il l
probablement le visa
quand même aller sur Internet
remplir des formulai
attendre ministère des affaires
étrangères. La signification
qu'on a vue jusqu'à présent du
gouvernement canadien et qu'on
craindrait qu'il y ait des
éléments prorusse qui
profiteraient de ce pont aérienr
le manipuler comme histoire à
mon avis.
- Très bien. Est-ce que vous
avez de l'espoir vous quand vous
avez entendu hier Justin je
reprends avec vous après enapaën
continue à se parler.lelelelele.
Il y avait un rapprochement,
donc deux parties qui disaient
qu'on était proche, peut-être
quelques jours pour avoir un
accord de cessez-le-feu.d'd'd'dd
c'est que les Russes disent: on
maintient nous-mêmes obnous-mêms
retirer nos troupes sans qu'on
ne va pas piller des villes.
-Rafaël Jacob et
Merci beaucoup